The taking of a bath, bathing,
sometimes it is taken the bath
in order to cool the body down due to
climatic conditions and other times it
is taken to remove sexual impurity.
Is this a permitted act during the fast?
Alhamdulillah
as far as
bathing is concerned that isul
whether it's done for
religious fur if you are in the state of
junu that's sexual defilement or whether
it is done to clean your body to remove
the dirt or you're feeling sticky or
whether bathing is done because you're
feeling thirsty or you're feeling hot.
Whatever reason it's done for as long as
the person does not swallow water
the fast does not get invalidated. So
bathing is permissible while fasting and
there are several a hadith to show that
it's permitted.
It's mentioned in say bkari volume
number three in the book of fasting
hadith number 1926
that aisha may Allah be pleased with
her. She says that the prophet he got up
from his sleep
in a sexually defiled state in the state
of Junub
while he was fasting and he took a bath
and he continued his fast that means
bathing was obligatory here because he
had intercourse with the wife so it was
compulsory and he bathed it. Further if
you read Sunan Abu Daud volume number
two in the book of fasting had number
Abu Bakr may Allah be pleased with him
he says that he heard a man saying that
when the prophet had gone to alge and
while he was fasting he poured water
over his head
because he was thirsty or he was feeling
excessively Not. So even when you feel
thirsty or you feel hot, you're allowed
to pour water over your head or have a
bath in the state of fasting. Further
mentioned in say bkari
number three in the book of fasting
chapter number 25
may Allah be pleased with him. He soaked
his garment in water and he wore it.
In the same chapter s bkari volume
number three in the book of fasting
chapter number 25 it's mentioned that
may Allah be pleased with him he says he
had a tub of water in which he used to
sit while he used to fast. So all these
hadith show us that taking guul pouring
water over your head whether it be for
religious purpose whether it's fur
whether it's optional muba whether
you're feeling excessively hot whether
you're feeling dirty whether you're
feeling thirsty in the state of fasting
all these are permissible as long as we
do not swallow water while having a bath